public the work session on session on
senate bill 445
fn
this was presented this morning
to full finance
along with an amendment
and
so what's under consideration right now
is
445 or 445 as amended
and apparently there's some in interest
in having a discussion about the
amendment or the verbiage
i guess would be in the basic bill and
the amendment as far as starting
construction
so why don't you
represented mooney you have you have a
concern thank you mr chairman in the
hennessey amendment so that's number
2022 hyphen 1351 s
lines 11 through 13.
the purpose of this amendment offered by
the senator is to add the word
successfully
before challenges i understand that
but there was there was discussion
at the hearing this morning about that
sentence and it is a little
clumsy
my thought is
if we take out the words beginning at
the end of line 11 because
starting in line 12 construction has
commenced
if those four words were deleted
to me it seems like the sentence would
be clearer
but i'm guessing there are
reasons for why
those words were in the original bill
and the hennessey amendment and it's my
understanding a member of the audience
can speak to that verbiage
please
but if i can just observe it changes the
meaning if you take those words out
you've got to turn the mic on
i appreciate the opportunity thank you
for the record my name is maura weston
i represent the new england cable and
telecommunications association
could you spell your name sure
no
problem maura
m-a-u-r-a
westin w-e-s-t-o-n
thank you i would have misspelled moro
thank you no problem
um i represent the new england cable and
telecommunications association during
the hearing this morning you heard from
chris hodgdon from comcast who is a
member of our association
he couldn't be here this afternoon so
i'll try to pick up where he left off
with some explanation about that
sentence which was
very deliberately added into the senate
version of the bill
the reason for that is and i think
as a lay person i can best explain it
with a with an example
if comcast has agreed to
go into community and invest its own
capital for example
to deploy to
say an additional certain number of
homes
a competitor
may not know or be aware that comcast is
actually
the gun construction for example
the make ready process
you may not see the wires being strung
but the process is underway
so under this particular initiative
if i as a competitive provider
put an application for a grant
to go build in that area where comcast
is already under construction
i shouldn't be eligible
for access to those taxpayer dollars
to fund essentially an overbuilt
where private
capital is already being spent
i have no way of knowing that
but comcast of course knows where they
are
so they can say as part of a challenge
process
there's a reason why this applicant
shouldn't be funded
and they can demonstrate
uh that they're there that they're
providing service or that they will be
providing service
and that will be
a successful challenge
of an applicant's eligibility for
funding because construction has
commenced
so comcast in this example has commenced
construction
i'm seeking dollars to build the same
area
not knowing that they're under
construction
it's up to comcast to say as part of a
challenge process
they're not eligible for this funding to
overbuild
does that help
yes that's the best explanation i've
heard so far thank you
i'm giving it my best and i will add
it's a little bit tricky because the
amendment as you see it is out of
context of the of the statute
and that makes it a little bit tricky
but i'll add to that that in the
amended version that came from the
senate
we added
that construction has commenced when a
provider initiates the make ready
process or begins construction of
broadband infrastructure in the project
area
the reason for that addition was uh
specifically
um
certain senators were interested in more
a morton
a definitive
explanation as to what construction has
commenced would mean they thought that
that phrase was a little bit vague so
with the addition
of that language they were comfortable
that
um not only would the providers know
when construction has commenced but it
would be an appropriate
um
definition guardrail etc
what are you reading from
i'm reading from senate bill 445 as
amended by the senate
and i was referencing lines
14 15.
so and the the whole the whole
premise of this
to take a step back and look at it from
the sort of the big picture
is that
i think
the stakeholders generally
are working to ensure the highest and
best use of taxpayer dollars so that
those taxpayer dollars can be invested
in areas where there is not service
where it's unserved and so this
particular provision allows a provider
who's already in one area to say we're
here
those taxpayer dollars shouldn't be
directed to this particular geographic
location
so with that explanation seeing that you
got all of that out of this you know i
don't think this is worth an amendment i
myself would not have written that
sentence that way
but again with your explanation drawing
that out of that i'm
fine to not tinker with that
myself representative
thank you mr chairman and
thanks for your explanation it helped me
as well so
i don't know if you were there this
morning when i asked the question over
in peterborough which is an area that
has been underserved
consolidated came in using
federal dollars to oversaturate where
comcast already was
can you give me an explanation why they
would be
hitting an area for the second time when
we already get these areas of the state
that the 30 000 i think was mentioned
sure
that's a great question and i think what
you highlight is an incredibly important
concept here
we're talking about a very competitive
industry
the telecom industry isn't isn't is just
robustly competitive you have
consolidated cci going out and investing
where comcast is already serving and in
fact with our within our cable
association we have breeze line formerly
atlantic broadband
uh now deploying in for example concord
where comcast has been our incumbent
um so even within the cable industry we
now have vibrant competition
so why would that happen
uh because every one of my clients and
cci would say the same thing
everybody's going to fight for every
customer where there is a business case
to be made to fight for those customers
what this program is getting at
is the instances where they can't make
that business case to go in and invest
the in those unserved areas
so you know i i can't speak to cci's
business plans or their decision making
but it's a great example of the robust
competition that we see
and why we want to keep these dollars
these federal dollars focused on
the unserved
thank you you're welcome
does that mean that
let's pick on the concrete example sure
comcast has got blind strong or are they
responsible for who strung them i don't
know
they're operating in now so another
company could come in and
add additional lines
absolutely
so there's a process now i'm not going
to pretend to be the technical expert by
any stretch
but um what i can tell you is atlantic
broadband now breeze line
went to the city of concord they
obtained a franchise agreement to
provide video service and also
internet broadband service and concord
comcast
offers
similar services
consolidated in concord offers similar
services so we're very fortunate in
concord now we have a choice of multiple
providers
offering us internet access video
etc so absolutely there's a process to
go through to obtain a competitive
franchise there's a process to go
through which is the make ready process
to access the poles and to string the
fiber
and who wins the people who own the
polls
i hope the consumers win right we all
want more choices that's true too
okay any other questions
oh
i don't know the answer to that i can
find out
yeah there there are a lot of um folks
out there right now deploying so i'll
find out for you
i'm sorry i didn't hear the question
any other questions
does anyone else like to speak to this
bill
this is a work session so we're happy to
work thank you for the opportunity thank
you moro
well i just want to clear up something
because i'm i'm
a little unsure and i'd look to the lba
on this one because right before the
meeting we're talking about
this amendment that has the word
successfully in it
am i looking at 445
a
i mean is this already amended
or do we need to
have our own amendment that says the
same thing as this amendment sure
researcher so um the amendment that
you're looking at that senator senator
hennessey brought forth the um 1351 s
that was never officially adopted so if
you are interested in adding that word
successfully we will have to get another
amendment drafted in your name if you'd
like and that's the one that you will
vote on you can vote on it today even
though you don't have it in front of you
and i'll work with ols to get that done
hopefully by the end of today but if you
do want to add that work word
successfully you do need an amendment
let me just
representative hatch you look puzzled
welcome to the club
on line 16 of the basic build
you insert the word
uh a provider who successfully
challenges yeah that's the only
difference
and and i the the subtlety there for me
is that anybody could challenge
that could
gum up the works but they have
successful
well what we're actually voting on is
this hennessy amendment with a new name
on top yeah
okay
do you know do you know why
the senate didn't act on the uh
on the amendment
i'm i'm not sure i think um it was found
after that they needed to add that word
successfully after it had been voted on
on the senate floor uh so then they
corrected this but it didn't get caught
prior to the prior to the crossover
okay
amendment moved by representative we
have a second
second second representative mooney
clarification
um
we're voting on the hennessey amendment
but it's going to be renamed
it'll be renumbered now
i have problems with the procedure i
mean we're assuming that nothing's going
to go wrong and we're going to get
another number so
that's why i was just saying
it's only one word
if you like gambling with his money
i'm still i'm still not comfortable
because i know it's assuming things are
going to be going correctly bothers me
okay you got to turn it on
you got to turn your mic on
oh
sorry if i may mr chairman who made the
motion and the second representative
hatch made the motion and represented
mooney second
record
okay
right just we're voting on the amendment
right now
okay okay we're all set
okay if you're in favor of the amendment
if you're in favor of the amendment
you'll vote in the affirmative if not
you'll vote on yeah in the negative
all right with that i'll call the roll
mr chairman yes
uh vice chairman yes clark votes yes
representative mooney yes representative
leishman yes representative hatch
mary beth i'm sorry representative walls
yes okay seven or nothing the motion
pass
okay thank you yeah
mr chairman
mr chairman i'll make a motion that we
accept senate bill 445 as amended okay
second seconded by representative mooney
we're all set you know the drill
all right uh mr chairman yes okay vice
chairman yes uh the clerk wrote cs
representative mooney yes a rep leashman
yes representative hatch representative
walsh yes mr chairman that voted seventh
or nothing it ought to pass as amended
okay so we will report this to the full
finance as octopass as amended
i have no idea
okay any other any other business for
this for division one
all right well enjoy the rest of your
week and the weekend
sessions is adjourned
actually mr chairman we just got a
notice
looks like
april 26th full finance will meet in an
exact session we're meeting on april
26th
10 a.m
so you'll you'll check with
the the writing crowd and get a number
to
represent diverge
okay yeah
yeah okay good then i'll correct it in a
minute all right thank you very much
you